quickly look you've done this question
already I want to read it to you and
then we'll just have a look briefly at
how I've set it up and how I think it -
let me read this to you really quickly a
car salesperson and this commission for
one week if his tumor cells were that
much calculate the rate of commission as
a percentage okay pause for a second
this mate now you can see I've already
done the usual thing of writing down the
essential details well this kind of a
catch
it's kind of difficult right I've left
this question on the board that we did
earlier because it's sort of similar the
language is so similar but it's not like
the actual mathematics of it it's kind
of different watch right you can see
I'll put a commission here in the
commission here but these two things are
obviously not talking about the same
thing because this is of the same and
this is an actual amount okay now part
of me is kind of like why why do you do
this textbook why do you use the same
word and why do you use it to mean
different things and the answer is
welcome to real life
where the same word depending on context
right so you look at things and when you
see that this is what he's earned really
what this number represents is that
about right what goes over there on the
left hand side okay mercifully sales
still needs a safety sales still means
sales what that means is when I put
together my equation it's gonna look a
bit different right instead of having
this equals a couple of numbers right in
fact I already know what the innings all
right so I'm gonna start right out the
game by saying seven eight
3:20 that's the first thing it equals
and then I've stopped because I don't
know what the percentage is why don't
know what the percentage because that's
what the question is right so this is
where algebra comes in why did we do
algebra for we did finance right because
it helps teach in the soon power of
algebra is working with numbers even you
don't know what the numbers are just
give it a name and you just go for it
I've called it C Commission and it's a
percentage multiplied by the eternal
cents and I have a value over there so
I'm just going now most people as they
did this question realize that division
was going to be necessary but they
didn't know what kind of division the
numbers are like upside down people got
two views that will happen if you don't
be careful when you're working once you
see me write this which I've just based
on the obvious questions on you before
if I try to solve for this they give me
cratons you got before right what would
I do to put signs to get super set by
itself yeah I'm going to divide by the
sales amount right 54 1 having divided
on both sides that's why it cancels off
of the right-hand side right so this is
going now and this is the actual
division I do now one last but you need
to do it before you put this into your
calculator at home when you hit equals
on that fraction right if I remember
correctly you're actually going to get
0.15 yes
now this is not the unsub it's not the
outside
watch out the way notes that the answer
is the questions asking for the
percentage right now this has a percent
inner what does percent meet again what
am i dividing by a hundred right so in
fact the greater looks like this the
percentage sign kind of hides that right
what I want is C by itself so I need to
multiply third
and that gives me and parts on so just
like I saw here 7% 14 and a half percent
is the entrance can you start off just
by saying 100 times okay so some people
like to put in the 105 over here like
they just write out the game I'm working
out of the city
that's fine the only reason I'm
hesitated from doing that is because
like why did you have that one over
there
it was it because it's a percentage
question in this crystal multiplied by a
hundred that's a it's a right cool
it's like why is that really the case
why is that true I think this kind of
makes Apple obvious why because that's
what percent means now we're getting rid
of that just want to get the other by
itself that's why I multiply by if you
write down if you did this right you
don't get forty two point five get this
that would be a cache because this
domain and its number are the same so
you've got this wrote that down so
unless you actually say then you're
multiplying by a hundred that you show
the transition a big error that students
papers they just do they working because
if they get community oh I bet multiply
by a hundred so it's like funny pitch
for a wild one hooked up over their
peers witness assault you just like to
send it in the fifth line even their
lines one two three point in pattern you
can just about convenient it's going to
come from somebody fine so
for ten minutes
okay so what you need to doing is with
this table you try and read right you
need to fit into account according to
that amount which were noticed wife
which one of the rows do I fit in - yeah
and then you were to line our rule so
for exact like did you for ABCD was
there a particular one you struggle we
got all the food right so princess or
did Festival
did you notice there's also a retainer
it sounds like you've done if the way
you described it sounds for exactly the
way I would go to hole for zero but
that's the retainer plus 24 890 is that
second teacher artists in the table I
would say now what's this
it says sales only 15,000 writers how
much is it sold and the answer
increasing two four eight nine zero
takeaway 15,000 IMG we've got that table
you have to read it very carefully